1 2 3 4
Bóc nhỉ đang hành hành hành hành hành hành
Càng ngay nhảy thì cơm hơn 1 chó của cơm mèo
Thì lúc thủ cân cũng như nguyên được con vài thử các mèi có gì bất thường
Được đi hành ngay hỏa nhất có lẽ là tìm để phương tị vý trụ để vỷ phí hút
Vậy chừng xây nào cũng vịt cho cơm bèo
Thá là bị đập tục điều rơi vào tình một ngày thì mình sẽ chọn bóc khá thủ cân
Đây là tình ăn tàn cho những bạm cầm gì chuyện cùng thủ cân
Mình chỉ cần là chọn bạm cầm cân trong chủ đặt sẽ
Thì có thể tâm điều có dí khả mất ở đi bất cứ lời đâu
Con sớm thì sao?
Phượng bạm năng măng thái thần từ bạy và có lẽ thảm đi kì và châu nay
Tìm nhiên mạnh có khu khóc gấp tệ khách hàng, sử lý về ngày sau đây
Phuân mình được mấy sinh sọng, cho chỉ đi khảm đi kì đâu
Và cô bạm đây gì thì bộ mình được lý gà 8 cí cho lẽ sợ
Mà đấu khả lúc nào cũng trục đặc đồ đâu
Lúc thì bạm cáo cũng thì họt lúc thì trải sống mà để vợ đi bộ mình thì không biết tập
Mình cũng tìm hiểu mình lại pháp đi, có ra tình từ phòng mâm
Hãy đấu vật đi khám, chủ đặc mặc cũng đất át được hơn
Và các đoạn có sản của ra tình tật thì có này có thêm nhiều ui đại
Tật khách chuyến, ra káp lơc, có điểm đón, học trả, và các bệnh biện, học không mẹ ngọt
Và đi khám tự xuyên, kết được khá nhiều trị phí dí truyền
Để nhà không chưa bạm đần cá, tình ra đây, mặc không phải là tất cả một mình
Từ đi chợ, đưa đón con đi học, chăm sóc mẹ và bẻ hay cạnh thình mình đặc biệt cho ra đình
Tụ ra cho khả nhà măng để những dải pháp thiết thường
Tìm mỗi thình viên cho ra đình được trong sof thuật tệ hơn
Các bạn thì sao để gử rác chia sẻ bớt tịch ra cho bạc ngay hôm nay
Và đừng quên để lại bị gửa chia sẻ trảy nghiệm với bây giờ video này nhé